I want to be bigger than Adele that
should be your goal yeah the word Adele
is just something that no one should
with basically what's the worst that
could happen to work where's it gonna
happen as you fail I've only written
songs from from their heart I want to
keep having stuff to do every day
what's that believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe and I believe that
you have the ability to do something
special that can change the planet so to
help you on your journey today we're
going to learn from singer-songwriter ed
Sheeran and my take on his top ten rules
for success vol 2 rule number one is my
personal favorite and I'd love to know
which one you guys liked the best
[Music]
now I read that your goal is to sell 20
million copies of this album divided
mm-hmm and you want to overtake Adele in
terms of record sales yeah and I feel
like me saying this a lot of people were
like that's such an arrogant thing to
say in but it's I think you need to
choose someone that's at the top if they
get low I probably won't sell 20 million
records and I probably won't ever be as
big as Adele but if you don't aim for
the top of the mountain how are you ever
gonna get halfway right and set high
goals for yourself yeah so but the
problem is that my point never comes
across with that because that quote is
now just I want to be bigger than
Adele's that should be your goal yeah
the word Adele is just something that no
one should if you put that into any
sentence prepare to be like chopped down
I don't play with a band I use this I
use a sample pedal which is all live and
built up so Wembley was always like even
an arena I thought I couldn't do an
arena so but then when I did an arena
and it was fine I was like well we might
as well try Wembley like it's not what's
the worst that could happen - what was
it good happen as you fail yeah and but
you're still sold Wembley so don't the
worst that were worse that could happen
is you fail and you move back to the
arena switch is not you know that's what
everyone else does so that's like it's
it's it's quite a cool thing baby Ricky
over there
it was at 87,000 every night 87,000 yeah
it's a big old stadium the stadium but
the thing is like if you fail you've not
lost anything and if you if you achieve
and make it good the possibilities are
endless
how imposing is social media on your
life did you just get sick of it you
just wanted to detox no it is you know I
I enjoy getting diving into it and kind
of being on it but it's just quite toxic
- but you just end up getting really
self-conscious about yourself and I'm
not like it I wasn't a huge yourself
conscious guy before and then you just
read into everything and like you kind
of end up searching for people slagging
you off and like looking for people
saying mean things
yeah and since I've been off it it's
been glorious I want a 30-year career
not a five-year career I don't want I
don't want to do it all up you know
we could have done stadiums a lot early
on we could have done arenas a lot
earlier and we could have released five
albums in in five years but it's a
marathon not not a sprint and I remember
being around a lot of my contemporaries
that were doing so much better than me
and my manager being like slow down just
slow down slow down and now I'm still
here six years on and they're not and I
think like the whole the whole music
industry you just need to just pace
yourself just to take time to make great
albums you don't you don't have to stick
out music or all the time to stay
relevant
you'll stay relevant by making great
records and to make great records you
have to spend a lot of time student I've
only written songs from from their heart
I don't really see the point of making
music if it's not an expression of self
or a form of therapy you know it's like
if I have a bad day I want to write a
song I don't want to write a song to
have a hit I want to write a song
because I want it to make me feel better
so yeah it's it's it's never been about
the audience or pleasing people or
trying to fit in it's just been about
myself and my love for music and I guess
that has come across I think this album
is very much it's rooted in my comfort
zone but there are certain times where I
step out of the comfort zone and the
reason I chose sing has to sort of lead
single for it that being step out of the
comfort zone is I had an acoustic ballad
song I wanted to put out first and
whenever I played its people they were
like no it's nice yeah really cool
really nice song when you played sing to
people it really polarized everyone they
were like they'd hated it with a loved
it but they spoke about it a lot you
know he'd speak to people to be like oh
yeah I heard about that song because
so-and-so is talking about it but no one
was talking about the acoustic King so I
thought by sticking out a song that sort
of makes people talk it would be a lot
better for the album I do I do work hard
and I do try and keep keep going but it
could be a lot worse this is the best
job I could possibly have and I I could
be working in a supermarket or something
like this is that this is the the days
off that don't exist because I don't
want them to exist I want to keep having
stuff to do every day it excites me to
travel around the world and play for
people that genuinely love all music and
smile and they're all happy in people
they're nice to me when we do interviews
and stuff it's it's good I've made this
album on tour
and I'm making the next album on tour
and it's about finding this home like
I've got a producer to bring a mobile
studio into every dressing room if I go
into an every hotel room and on this all
bus so in between doing meet-and-greets
and the gig he will try and write a song
and then after the gig he will try and
write a song and then on the bus
journeys the next place we try and write
a song so it's about finding the time to
make it happen for me success is always
stepping out on stage and feeling people
genuinely happy to hear your songs yeah
that's that's always been when I when I
know as songs a hit is when you play it
and a crowd you just see people light up
in the crowd and smile I think that's
that's how you know rather than seeing
stats and figures Hey stats and figures
are great as well to look at and you
know everybody everyone needs a ego
massage sometimes but I think the gigs
gigs are the ones
[Music]
you're right
[Applause]
baby
[Applause]
[Applause]
I
honey man
[Music]
maybe
[Applause]
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because who some as he
asked me to if there's someone you'd
like to vote on for the next top 10
check out the link in the description
and go and have your say finally I want
to give a quick shout out to Jason beam
Jason thank you so much for picking up a
copy of my book your one word and for
posting the video about it on your
youtube channel I really appreciate the
support man and I'm so glad you enjoyed
the read there is your one word heaven
Carmichael's so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon
[Music]
embrace your quirks and embrace your
witness and from a from a starting point
of view don't don't treat it as an issue
you know work work through it and get
the treatment that you you want to get
but don't don't ever treat it as an
issue and don't see it as am a plight on
your life the thing that makes you cool
is as you said earlier not given and I
are never going to hide the fact that
I'm a very competitive person I do want
this to be the biggest album in the
world and I'm going to make sure it is
the biggest album in the world there's
gonna be no no stone left on tap on turn
I love that you have totally stayed true
to yourself and your songs with your
style just with your career in general
so if you could I would like to know how
you would encourage other young
20-somethings to say treating themselves
without letting other people bring them
down no one can be you better than you
can I know that's quite a quite an
obvious thing but I think I think people
forget that people try to model
themselves on what and what other people
are doing and like everyone has their
flaws and flaws are what make you human